mercedes-benz vans has presented its new
X class stylish explore concept car in
Stockholm along with a powerful engine
the new premium pick up offers high
driving comfort and safety it's also
touted as robust and suited for offroad
use but why combine premium and pick up
and pick up daimler's chairman of the
board at essentia says premium pickup is
the only segment the company hasn't
covered yet and it's an important
segment that Daimler wants to move into
in the future so India humid gets to
come sail bunkin along with powerful
adventure mercedes has produced another
slightly changed concept the stylish
explorer
Khun visas in dieter said she points out
that Daimler is presenting two concept
cars that's what's special about this
pick up on the one hand is positioned as
a classic traditional vehicle for car
buyers who want to transport cargo in
the country but on the other hand it has
strong lifestyle appeal you can drive it
to the Opera Daimler is presenting this
combination as the salient feature of
both concept cars the plans to unite
production in one vehicle with several
versions Edmund I'm thoughts of machine
Alliance salutis in the product CO and
done fighting Daimler expects the X
class pickups primary markets to be
Latin America and South Africa and
Europe Germany will play a major role
the truck makes for private driving fun
with the family or friends and
commercial use in one vehicle
amox fixed Edith tsecha says the market
is growing fast from two million
customers to a projected 2.8 million by
the year twenty twenty-five he says now
is the perfect time to enter this market
for a rosy future perfect atty beulah
the concept x-class aims to set new
standards for comfort safety and design
in the midsize pickup segment the top
model will have a v6 diesel engine and
the 4matic permanent all-wheel drive a
22 inch metal alloy wheels and
anthracite chrome underscore the premium
look of the stylish Explorer
in the interior are brown nubuck leather
white nappa leather and decorative oaken
aluminum details then pure luxury Gordon
and hot sake the Daimler executive says
the company wanted to develop a vehicle
that stands out from the crowd and gives
the pickup segment a powerful whiff of
premium and he think it has succeeded
with this design and this technology
that belong to them the powerful
adventure is a real workhorse it's
brawny designed commands immediate
respect the wheel wells are not made of
plastic but matte carbon fiber the
electric winch on the front catches the
eye and says this car can move mountains
the rectangular rear with a trailer
hitch also stands for strength and
durability
there are carbon fiber components in the
interior to the color accents harmonized
with the exteriors green paint
high-gloss black nappa leather and green
decorative stitching round out the
overall appearance Mercedes will build
the X class pick up jointly with a
renault-nissan alliance the basic
technology and the production will be
shared with this son's navara production
begins in 2017 in the Nissan Plant and
Barcelona we can't wait to see what
Mercedes unveils in the late 2017